whoa dude everybody's favorite actor
kiana reeves recently took part in an
interview with siriusxm
accompanied by his buddy and bill and
ted based the music co-star alex winter
asked if there were any characters he
wished he could travel back in time to
play
reeves didn't hesitate to name drop a
certain grizzled canadian adamantium
infused mutant
as reeves put it i always want to play
wolverine
winter who didn't seem at all surprised
by this immediately chimed in with
it's not too late it is too late it's
not too late for kiara to play wolverine
i'm just going to leave
that there reeves though disagree saying
it's too late the role has been filled
really well and i'm all good with it now
reeves likely knew that what he was
saying was going to send x-men fans into
a tizzy
the x fandom has long linked the actor
with that particular role and when it
came time for hugh jackman to step down
from the park speculation ignited anew
that marvel might take a look at reeves
to play the next iteration of wolverine
in the marvel cinematic universe
of course there's probably no way that
will happen following disney's
acquisition of fox marvel studios boss
kevin feige is taking over the x-men
movie franchise and is reportedly
looking to recast wolverine with a
younger actor
with the potential exception of deadpool
the entire x-men lineup will likely be
recast with younger stars reeves is
almost a whole 4 years older than
jackman who's in his early 50s making
his chances of playing a wolverine slim
to none
unless marvel wanted to employ him for
flash forward sequences at some point
just to be clear though reeves didn't
bring up wolverine just a toy with fans
hearts
when asked to confirm that he was
serious about his pining for the role
the actor said quote
oh yeah frank miller's wolverine for
sure there are about a million reasons
why frank miller is a comics legend and
for marvel the writer and artist did
some of his most tremendous work
in the early 80s miller successfully
rebooted daredevil
many of the traits we now take for
granted about matt murdock his strong
moral code his catholicism his tortured
inner battle over his crime-fighting
career or miller's doing
in 1982 miller and the equally legendary
comics writer chris claremont were
sharing a cab on the way back from san
diego comic-con when they conceived the
idea for a four-part mini-series
centered on wolverine the x-man who had
swiftly risen to become one of marvel's
most popular characters since his 1974
introduction
thanks to claremont's stark writing and
miller's kinetic expertly laid out
panels the miniseries which ran from
september to december 1982 became a
massive hit
the series did for james howlett aka
logan what miller's daredevil run had
done for matt murdock
strongly establishing his
characterization motivations and
backstory in a way that would come to
define him for decades
doing a little quick math reeves would
have just turned 18 years old when the
debut issue of miller's wolverine
dropped in 1982 so we can't say we're
surprised it had a lasting effect on it
unfortunately as reeves himself noted
that ship has pretty much sailed
while that doesn't mean the chances of
seeing him in the mcu in some capacity
are totally squashed
marvel enthusiasts have been fan casting
reeves in all kinds of mcu roles for
years now and if there's one thing we
know about kevin feige it's that he's
keen to give the fans what they want
last summer during the press tour for
spider-man far from home
feige was asked if reeves had ever been
considered for a role in a marvel flick
feige replied we talk to him for almost
every film we make
i don't know when if or ever he'll join
the mcu but we very much want to figure
out the right way to do it
feige wasn't just whistling dixie he
went on to compare the situation with
reeves with a casting of jake gyllenhaal
with whom he said marvel had also spoken
about a bevy of different roles before
he was finally cast as quentin beck
aka mysterio and far from home so while
reeves may not be suiting up as
wolverine we're pretty sure that sooner
or later feige will find a way to bring
the world's most beloved actor into the
world's biggest movie franchise
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one